[Music]
so it's a typical Thursday night as a
third year gone are the days of beer
pong Thursdays and I will hunch it over
my computer in the basement of Wong
engineering building the clock ticking
toward the deadline at 11:00 for the
past year as part of my joint degree
program I've been trying to teach
machines how to learn like humans but
I'm here today to tell you about the
time the machines taught me something
about how to learn and live more fully
so that day in the basement I'm building
this program that's supposed to learn
how to play blackjack on its own using a
type of machine learning called
reinforcement learning which is the same
kind that was used by google's alphago
but unlike alphago my program is acting
like a kid that never learns it keeps
making the same mistakes like hitting on
19 or 20 and sometimes standing pad on 3
for those of you who are not non-blood
up about blackjack players those are not
good moves to make I'm super frustrated
see what my program is supposed to do is
actually quite intuitive it only needs
to do two things first it's just as any
kid would do when given a new toy it's
supposed to try out a bunch of things
and collect experiences like try hitting
on 10 or 15 or 20 and experience what
happens and second it's supposed to stop
and extract lessons from those
experiences learn things like aha
whenever I choose hit when I'm on 20 bad
things happen not going to do that again
so I spend an hour of debugging and I
feel like my soul just got sucked out of
my body and and I realized that I've
somehow built a program that's doing a
great job of collecting experiences
running around doing all these things
and not stopping to learn anything from
those experiences too busy running
around to learn anything from experience
that actually didn't sound that
unfamiliar
as no stranger to what seems to be the
GSB mantra of do more fit more stuff in
schedule and be more productive I saw a
little bit of myself in that program I
had to ask myself am I like that program
to RV like that program that never
learns from experience so unfortunately
I realized yes I was like that program
more than once for example I walked out
of class thinking wow that speaker had
such clarity of thought I'd love to
learn how to do that and I never did
because I had to run to the next BDL or
the next coffee chat I never took the
time to think through which of his
comments struck me as insightful and
what it would look like if I try to
imitate that line of thinking on a
different topic so you might be thinking
wait a second were not like computers
important things will stick in my memory
in our memory even if we don't stop and
reflect right that's exactly what I was
thinking too and to see if it was true
and I really wanted it to be true I
decided to re-examine a learning moment
from my own experience to see if I truly
got out everything that I should have
knowing that I didn't have the time to
reflect on that experience the
experience that came to my mind was one
of my proudest moments from army days in
Korea cleaning the second-floor bathroom
so I had just made corporal that month
it's a pretty good deal you know I was I
had this new prestigious responsibility
as the leader of the cleaning squad so
ten or so privates from my platoon who
cleaned after work every day and how we
clean these places never changes
overtime in a barrack dominated by this
oppressive hierarchical culture you
simply do what you're told by your
superiors but this time we really want
you to bring some fun and creativity
into this so for the first couple days
two privates walked around and jotted
down what everyone was doing at any
moment then they learn to create this
chart that showed us the sequence of
activities that we are
took and where the bottlenecks were true
consultant style and and with that we
debated how to make our process better
we'd ask things like to redouble the
personnel for wiping the toilet so
whoever's watering down doesn't have to
wait or we're using toothbrushes to
clean the urinals not ours but the spare
one but the surface area is too small so
it takes a long time to clean how can we
get normal brushes we try to having two
area captain's as well as having one
centralised cleanings our system and
after a month of experiments we cut down
the time from 30 minutes to 14 minutes
and you might be wondering if I'm being
facetious about this being one of my
proud moments but I'm kind of not and if
anybody asks what do you learn from that
experience I'd say something like this I
learned how to motivate a team give
ownership and change an organizational
culture a financer specific enough to
fool others and most importantly myself
that I've learned enough from that
experience but if anybody further pushes
and asks me but really how do you give
ownership what actionable insights did
you learn from that experience you can
use here and now I de stumped I have
this log of experience in my head but
contrary to my hopes my brain didn't
magically distill insights from that
experience sure some of those had popped
up in my head before but I assume those
were important enough to stick in my
memory and sure enough they did it so
one weekend I spent 30 minutes to
reflect on that experience and the
lessons I walked away this time were of
completely different resolution for
example I learned about the moment that
I become susceptible to inadvertently
taking ownership away from my team and
how to counteract that temptation or the
tactics I can use to address norm by
elations in a stern way when I'm also
trying to build a positive collaborative
culture so there it was the verdict
the high quality insights doesn't stick
in your memory automatically I had to do
the work to get them how much of
invaluable experience you're having here
at the GSB are you extracting lessons
from are you learning enough from your
experience so why did I bring up this
complicated computer algorithm to make a
simple point that we should stop and
reflect to learn because it exposes an
inconvenient truth when dealing with
fuzzy things that are hard to quantify
like self development or learning we
often choose to believe in mental models
that are convenient to us rather than
the ones that might be more accurate so
when it comes to our belief about how we
learn from experience it makes our life
so much easier to simply believe in this
mental model of aging whisky where as
with risky time takes care of everything
and it somehow magically distilled
insights from your subconscious
reservoir of experience but as much as I
love whisky
I believe fundamental the fundamental
relationship between experience and
learning is more accurately captured by
the mental model of that dumb blackjack
program if we don't stop and reflect we
will not learn we have to put in the
work to get what's important to us
because no one else not time not our
subconscious is going to do that job for
us so I hope this program to some
program could act as the same wake-up
call as it did to me and motivate you to
spend five minutes every day to make
sense of what happened that day I hope
we can all live and learn to be a little
better today than we were yesterday
you
[Applause]
[Music]